hello everybody my name is nyan i'm the
black female engineer i provide content
for new and aspiring software engineers
and today we are talking about the top
myths people have about
software engineers yeah y'all be
spreading spreading lies some of y'all
summing up so let's get number one i
think this myth is
kind of the most or ah like top two top
three of the most harmful ones because i
feel like it's this one that deters the
most people and that is you need to be
good at math
lies no you really don't software
engineering is just such a blanket
statement and there's so many specific
jobs and niches within it that not all
of them require you to be good at math
with what i do math really isn't a thing
if you know one plus one then
i think you're good i think you're good
because the only time i use math is when
it's needed for
the viewer so for example i want to
present a percentage on the viewer so
okay let me do x divided by y times 100
and i put that in there so the viewer
can see that percent
that is the extent of the math use um in
my specific job there are roles of
course in sectors and niches that do
require more extensive knowledge in math
and calculus and whatnot but if you
don't like math and you don't want to
deal with that
don't number two and i think this meshes
with number one a ton is that you need
to be the super genius to be a software
engineer this is something that a lot of
people say to me when they ask what i do
and say oh i'm a software engineer
they're like oh so you must be really
smart and like
well
to me it's always hard to follow that up
because my thing is like well you don't
need to be a genius to be a software
engineer that doesn't mean i'm not
really smart and i'm not saying no i'm
not smart but that doesn't necessarily
relate with one another it's like saying
oh i'm software engineers like oh so you
must love the color red it's like well
yeah i love the color red but
that doesn't have to do with
my success on the job really you know
what i mean it's not that you need to be
the super genius to be a software
engineer what you need to do is be a
problem
solver you need to be able to actually
like puzzles and getting things together
being able to see some gray area and
mesh the pieces together based on the
different information you find also kind
of like an investigator being able to
say like okay so this is the scene of
the crime right here as i'm really
talking about like broken code this is
the scene of the crime let me
see where i can get to resolve this to
figure out the solution for x y and z
google talking with other people stack
overflow x y and z let's see where we
can find answers and then bring it back
home with us i feel like a lot of people
specifically software engineers are
afraid to say that because
they're afraid of i don't even know
breaking that facade of like oh they're
uber smart and they know like yo like
let's call it for what it is like you
are just a really great problem solver
maybe you are super smart like i'm not
saying
software engineers are not super smart
but
being super smart and being just a hyper
genius does not necessarily mean that
you're going to be a good software
engineer and reverse not being a hyper
genius or super smart or whatever it
doesn't mean you're going to be a bad
software engineer it's all really
what it comes down to is your liking and
ability to solve puzzles number three i
really won't spend too much time on it
because that is what this entire channel
is devoted to and that is that you need
a computer science degree to be a
software engineer
you do not and i have a video above that
really goes more into this really goes
into top top top companies like google
like facebook like pinterest that hire
even if you don't have a degree
a degree not just like oh i don't have a
computer science degree but i have a
degree in interpretive dancing but like
no
home girl came out of high school with
her ged and
did the work and
now knows how to code and could get a
job at google and so that's what i'm
talking about there like you do not need
a degree you need to be able to do the
work and that's what's so beautiful
about this space this career is at the
end of the day
people just care that you can do the
work and so if you can do it great like
pull up a seat like damn come on so yes
that's number three number four software
engineers are introverts
that's quite the myth there are some
people who are introverts and there are
some people who are not like everything
and everywhere in life there are some
people who yeah like to do their work
stolen call it a day but
you need to be comfortable asking
questions and reaching out to people and
presenting i just now had a presentation
in front of project manager that i've
never met before in a whole different
departments little me presenting to
these 30 40 50 year old people
being like hey yeah so this is what's
what's going on and so yeah you need to
be able to communicate and be
comfortable doing so because you also
even if you're not presenting and things
like that you need to be able to
communicate your code and so it's not
enough for you to just know how to code
you need to know
how to communicate your ideas
communicate your questions and
communicate to other people to really be
that amazing developer in my eye yes
it's boring i don't really know where
the smith comes from i think maybe with
the idea
that oh as a software engineer you just
sit in front of a screen all day and
don't talk to anyone and that's just
your whole nine to five every single day
until they die i don't know if that's
where that
idea comes from that it's boring but i
love
my job y'all like i
constantly
be odd but i constantly have to make
myself not work on a weekend like i'll
be sitting here i'm like oh i don't
really have anything to do like i would
love to continue developing that web app
but be like no naya like no take take
the break take a second um and it's
truly because i just really love the job
you love the work and it comes from
loving puzzles and solving problems and
figuring out solutions that's what's
interesting to me that's what's
capturing me and if you're a person who
like let's say loves true crime
you likely would like
a career like this because and i i hate
i can't believe i'm thinking about crime
constantly thinking about this work and
whatnot but it truly often feels like
that like we are investigating solutions
to what's going on here especially when
you're doing bug fixes and someone
approaches you with x and x problems it
feels like you're a detective now like
okay let's see where went wrong let's
see all the different solutions let's
talk to these people get our heads
together and figure out a solution for
this i really love it and i love true
crime and it's because of that whole
detective aspect this whole problem
solving aspect which is the exact same
type of mind you need as a software
engineer and so no it is not boring at
all it's extremely exciting and
especially when you think about once you
solve that problem oh my goodness you
just want to leap up you want to call
everybody in their mama but then you
remember nobody cares
other than you like other than you so
you just kind of like do your happy
dance by yourself and call it a day but
no it is not boring like i said earlier
there's so many different sectors and so
many different niches in software
engineering and so you just need to find
that niche that
intrigues you the most and lastly that
you must be an expert at snx language
no no you just need to know how things
work enough that you can
get by
googling
[Music]
googling throughout your workday so i
my knowledge is in javascript that's how
i learned and my work has been in python
i google always till sunday
but i get my work done and pretty in my
opinion pretty okay time because
i know what
i know the steps to solving the problem
you know what i mean i know that i would
do like a for loop here and i would
create this function here but i may not
know python very well and so i just
google okay how to do a for loop how to
do x and x function and whatnot in
python and that's really what i do
constantly and then what's so funny is
the other day and i'm not afraid to say
this because i feel like a lot of people
be hush-hush about software engineering
making it
seem like nobody ever makes mistakes or
whatnot which is not true
but another day like literally like
minutes ago
i was out here developing in python and
then i had to switch over to a
javascript file and i needed a for loop
and i started writing the for loop in
like in with python syntax for those of
you who don't know syntax is basically
me trying to write an a book in english
but i'm using spanish words and so
i'm like wait no this isn't the right
you know syntax and whatnot but then for
the life of me i couldn't remember how
to do a for loop in javascript i was
like oh my goodness i've been doing for
those in python like how do i do it in
jobs and that's javascript is the
language i learned in and so i was like
oh my goodness not a girl you really
don't know
i said to google like yo google how siri
how do i do for loop in javascript again
and then i was like oh there we go and
then i coded that out and that's
extremely normal and extremely common
like it's not even something to blink
about or to lose sleep over or to like
even think about for a second there's
this mindset like oh like the really
good programmers they
do everything from their head they have
memorized every single type of function
and how to do x y and z and they just
code out at one time and boom there you
go and it wasn't until my instructor
from coding bootcamp said and i'm going
to butcher this so like if anyone from
google is watching this or
anything please don't come at me
the idea is there but the numbers will
be wrong but they were they said
something to the effect of
gmail if you code it out if you just try
to code the lines it takes only about
like let's say like eight to 12 hours to
code the program just coding it out
but when you think about
the amount of time it took to develop it
and the amount of people that had to
come together to develop it it took not
eight hours i can assure you that and
that's because you don't just know these
processes and these systems and these
functions and how to solve these
problems what you know is that you are a
problem solver and you will figure it
out you'll go to different people you go
to different resources you'll test and
test and test and try again and try
again and keep sticking and throwing
things at a wall until finally something
sticks and then you do it again for your
next line of code and your next line of
code so it takes weeks and months and
years to develop something that when
it's finished the coding of it actually
takes just hours to do and so remember
that when you are beating yourself up
for like oh shoot i don't i keep having
to google x x y z like no be comfortable
doing that because that's not going to
stop any time soon so there we go
everybody the top myths people have
about software engineers and kind of not
even people have about software
engineers but the top myths software
engineers may have about software
engineers and they might think that
they're like the bad software engineer
because they're not fitting into that
box like again like knowing languages at
an expert level or memorizing languages
and syntax and everything like no those
are myths calm down you're doing great
and so yeah hopefully that helps you
know just loosen you up a little bit
make you not as scared um to be in this
field if you're trying to be in this
field if you're new to this field
hopefully that eases your mind a little
bit and makes you a little bit more
comfortable because yeah i really want
to be super authentic on this channel
and tell you like no these are the
things i don't know these are the things
i don't know these are the things i
don't know and i think it's about time
more people started doing that and so
yeah let's let's start here and so
hopefully this was helpful and somewhat
entertaining but yes please leave your
comments below let me know what you
think let me know what myths or what
yeah what thoughts you have about
software engineers and let's start a
little conversation and so yes thank you
so much for watching and i'll see you
all later bye